yeah every move he's making with one or
two seconds left on the clock and he's
going to run out of time eventually at
this rate
and okay he does keep making moves with
one second now magnus three extra pawns
on that left side that's going to be
enough also no black knight is going to
stop white's pawn advancing this one is
has regained control after letting it
slip a bit earlier on
and yeah this one is almost over now
magnus only needing that draw all he
needs to do give up his knight for white
pawn
and that's game over there's no more
chances for white to win
once his pawn disappears and magnus's
king is
creeping forward and no how magnus's
rook
stops the advance of the white pawn
and uh you can see the strain on
wesley's face he knows it's over
he trades those rooks and now the black
king is marching towards the white pawn
once the white pawn drops
at the very least it's going to be a
draw for black and he's through to the
semis
yep and uh here comes one offer of an
exchange
there's nothing to do that's completely
winning actually exactly um those black
pawns are going to
win the day yeah and wesley's so smiling
he knows what's coming
magnus leaning back he's in control and
just get rid of that white pawn that's
all you want to do in situations like
this magnus doesn't even want to win he
lets all of his pawns fall
and we're about to see a draw wow what a
fight by wesley so though winning the
two final
games in the match magnus carlsen is the
winner though of this quarter final both
of the players shaking their heads
and we're seeing two smiles what a fight
again by these two fantastic players but
it is magnus carlsen
who is through to the semi-finals where
he will face
levon naronia yeah look at that smile on
magnus's face
obviously he's relieved and happy now i
guess
yeah once again